This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Fred Bryant studies a tragedy that affects millions of people around the world. Most of our lives are filled with ample examples of joy and sorrow when many of us preferentially focus on what is wrong. In our last episode, we examine how many of us say we want to be happy but spend much of our lives focused on things that make us unhappy. We pay attention to aches and pains, but take our bodies for granted when we are healthy. We complain about unpleasant coworkers and nasty neighbors, but don't talk much about the kind souls we know at work and in our communities.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家弗雷德·布莱恩特正在研究一种影响全球数百万人的悲剧。我们大多数人的生活中充满了快乐与悲伤的例子，但许多人却倾向于关注那些出错的事情。在上一集中，我们探讨了为什么许多人说自己想快乐，却把大部分时间花在让自己不快乐的事情上。我们关注病痛，却在健康时将身体视为理所当然。我们抱怨令人不快的同事和讨厌的邻居，却很少谈论我们在工作和社区中认识的那些善良的灵魂。
When good things happen to us, we wonder how they could be better. If you missed that episode, I strongly recommend you listen to it first. It has a number of important insights. We examine how sorrows have a way of finding us, no matter how hard we try to avoid them. Joy is on the other hand, don't come knocking. We have to find them. And when we do, we need to learn a number of mental skills to notice and save them.
当好事发生时，我们却在想它们本可以更好。如果你错过了那一集，我强烈建议你先去听听。它包含许多重要的见解。我们探讨了无论我们多么努力地去避免，悲伤总有办法找到我们。另一方面，快乐却不会主动敲门。我们必须去寻找它们。当我们找到快乐时，我们需要学习一些心理技巧来察觉并留住它们。
Today on the show, part two of our mini-series on the Science of Savoring. How you can deploy your mind to make yourself a happier person this week on Hidden Brain. You've heard the phrase, when life hands you lemons make lemonade? The advice tells us, make the best of a bad situation. Look on the bright side. Fred Bryant's mother, Mary Lee, was an expert at looking on the bright side. And she was a master when it came to savoring the pleasure in joyful experiences.
今天节目中，我们将播出关于“品味科学”迷你系列的第二部分。在本周的《Hidden Brain》中，你将了解如何运用你的思维让自己成为一个更快乐的人。你听过那句谚语吗：“当生活给你柠檬时，就把它做成柠檬水？”这句建议告诉我们，要从糟糕的境遇中寻找最好的一面，要往好处想。弗雷德·布莱恩特的母亲玛丽·李，就是一位“往好处想”的专家。而在品味快乐体验中的愉悦感方面，她更是一位大师。
She understood that savoring is a process that can begin long before the joyful thing happens. You can anticipate pleasures prospectively. And once something wonderful is over, you can remember pleasures retrospectively. Fred, who is now a psychologist at Loyola University, Chicago, said his mother was the inspiration for his own interest in studying the science of savoring. And her example turned out to be valuable when he suffered a serious medical setback in his 30s. Fred Bryant, welcome to Hidden Brain.
她明白，品味是一个过程，可以在快乐的事情发生前很久就开始。你可以预先期待快乐。而当美好的事情结束后，你也可以回顾性地回味快乐。弗雷德现在是芝加哥洛约拉大学的心理学家，他说他的母亲是他研究品味科学的灵感来源。当他在30多岁时遭遇严重的医疗挫折时，他母亲的榜样证明了其价值。弗雷德·布莱恩特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you, Sound Card, it's a pleasure to be here. Some years ago, Fred, you suffered a very serious back injury. I understand that you were in your basement doing a renovation. Tell me the story of what happened. My father and mother had come to visit. My dad was a handyman of sorts. He knew a lot about building and renovation. So I bought the lumber and the equipment, and we drew up a plan and began transforming the basement.
谢谢，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。弗雷德，几年前你遭受了非常严重的背部受伤。我听说当时你正在地下室进行装修。讲讲发生了什么事吧。我父母当时来看望我。我父亲算是个杂工，他很懂建筑和装修。所以我买了木材和设备，我们制定了计划，开始改造地下室。
We got to a point where we were nearly done. We had to put a door in a doorway between the basement and the laundry room. And I had ordered a fine door, very sturdy, heavy. I leaned it against the wall. We were next day, we were going to install it. I was in the basement, decided we were going to celebrate. So I ordered a pizza, and my younger daughter came down the stairs into the basement. I guess she was three at the time and began saying, oh is that the door? Is that the door? Is that the door?
我们快要完工了。我们需要在地下室和洗衣房之间的门口装一扇门。我订购了一扇很好的门，非常结实、沉重。我把它靠在墙上。我们打算第二天安装。当时我在地下室，决定庆祝一下，所以我点了披萨。我小女儿走下楼梯来到地下室。我想她当时大概三岁，开始问：“哦，那是门吗？那是门吗？那是门吗？”
I said, yeah, that's the door. But be careful, darling. It's heavy and stay back from it. So I was on the other side of the room and she said, I like the door. It's fun. And she was feeling the edges of the door. I said, be careful over there. I'm ordering the pizza. Turn, hadn't heard anything for a second or two. And that's always a strange sensation when your child talks a lot. So looked over and she was walking away from the door, but she had pushed it. It had bounced off the wall and was very slowly. Again, a fall forward onto her as she had turned her back and was walking from it.
我说：“是的，那是门。但要小心，亲爱的。它很重，离它远点。”我当时在房间的另一边，她说：“我喜欢这扇门。真好玩。”她正在摸门的边缘。我说：“在那边小心点。我正在点披萨。”我转过身，一两秒钟没听到声音。当你的孩子平时话很多时，这总是一种奇怪的感觉。所以我看过去，她正从门边走开，但她推了它一下。门从墙上弹开，非常缓慢地向前倒向她，因为她当时背对着门，正走开。
I realized there, I have a second act. This is not going to end well. So I threw the phone down and I dived across the room, caught the door right before it hit her and landed. And when I landed I twisted in a strange way and I felt a pop deep inside my lumbar in the spine. It was excruciating pain. I knew in an instant that I had done something profoundly wrong to my back, but I couldn't really get up.
我意识到，我有第二幕了。这结局不会好。所以我扔掉电话，冲过房间，在门砸到她之前接住了它，然后落地。当我落地时，我扭曲了一下，感觉到脊椎腰部深处“砰”的一声。那是剧痛。我瞬间就知道我的背部出了大问题，但我真的站不起来了。
I slithered up the stairs and got on the ice and then began to realize this is terrible, but maybe it'll go away. Well, it did not go away. You got worse, and it got worse, and I eventually saw Dr. recommended an MRI. The MRI showed that this was not a bulging disk, not a herniation. It was a total absolute blowout between the L5 and S1 vertebrae and pieces of it were in the spinal canal. The only recourse for me was going to be surgery. The positive was that it went very well where I had been unable to walk more than 50 feet at a time.
我爬上楼梯，敷了冰块，然后开始意识到这太糟糕了，但也许会好起来。好吧，它并没有好转。情况越来越糟，我最终看了医生，医生建议做核磁共振。核磁共振显示这不是椎间盘突出，也不是脱出。这是L5和S1椎骨之间彻底的爆裂，碎片进入了椎管。我唯一的出路就是手术。积极的一面是手术非常成功，我之前一次无法行走超过50英尺。
And my left leg beforehand had been shriveling, atrophying because the nerves were cut off and pressed. Afterwards, I had feeling in my foot and leg. And in a course of three months, I had gotten stronger. And I had been able to begin walking. The surgeon pronounced me well, intact, and ready to go forth and prosper. So I thought, wow, this is great. I cannot wait. I'm going to be able to go back to hiking and climbing. So tell me a little bit about that because you have this great passion for mountain climbing.
手术前，我的左腿因为神经被切断和压迫而在萎缩。手术后，我的脚和腿有了知觉。在三个月的时间里，我变得更强壮了。我已经能够开始走路了。外科医生宣布我康复了，身体完好，准备好继续前进并繁荣发展。所以我心想，哇，这太棒了。我等不及了。我将能够回去徒步和攀岩。那么，跟我说说那件事吧，因为你对登山有着极大的热情。
And I'm imagining that when you first had the injury, besides the excruciating pain which must have occupied all of your mind, very soon after, you must have started wondering whether your climbing days were over. Oh yeah, I was heartbroken that this passion had been taken from me well before I imagined my time. I thought, well, maybe I can do this. Maybe I can come back. The surgeon said, I'm good to go. So I thought, how about I'm going to plan this? We're going to go.
我想象当你第一次受伤时，除了占据你所有心思的剧痛之外，很快你一定开始怀疑你的登山生涯是否结束了。哦，是的，我心碎了，因为这种热情在我预想的时间之前就被剥夺了。我想，好吧，也许我能做到。也许我能回来。外科医生说，我没问题了。所以我心想，我该怎么计划呢？我们要出发了。
The family is going to go back to us, Virginia. My parents had a cabin deep in the woods near a big mountain. How about I go back and try to climb that mountain? Take the family and invite them to my favorite climbing buddies, friends from college, they were bringing their families. This was gonna be wonderful. It would be the first week in October. The leaves were at their absolute peak,
全家人要回到弗吉尼亚。我父母在森林深处有一间小屋，靠近一座大山。我回去尝试爬那座山怎么样？带上家人，邀请我最喜欢的登山伙伴，大学朋友，他们也会带上家人。这将会非常美妙。那将是十月的第一周。树叶正处于最绚烂的巅峰，
and this was a dream come true, to be able to return to this activity. So the plan was, everyone arrives and goes to the cabin. The next day, my friends and I are going to go up this hike. It's about 1,500 feet. I had done it before, several times, and loved it. At the end of the day, we were to have a major celebration where we were going to cook massive quantities of pasta. There would be great music. It was going to be a saver fest, retelling the story of how it felt to go up the mountain and back down again, finally, after all this time.
这是一个梦想成真，能够重返这项活动。所以计划是，大家到达并住进小屋。第二天，我和朋友们去徒步。大约1500英尺高。我以前爬过几次，非常喜欢。在一天结束时，我们要举行一场盛大的庆祝活动，我们要烹饪大量的意大利面。会有很棒的音乐。这将是一场品味盛宴，重温在经历了这么长时间后，再次爬上山顶又走下来的感觉。
If you have grand celebration, one for the ages. Yeah. So in some ways, you were doing the prospective savoring that we've talked about earlier, the idea that you're sort of anticipating and building up your anticipation and enjoying in some ways even before the event has actually taken place. Very much so, imagining it, the joy of it, reminding myself how much I wanted this to happen, and it finally was going to be able to happen. I mean, I had all my loved ones and closest people
如果有一场盛大的庆祝活动，那将是值得铭记的。是的。所以从某种程度上说，你正在进行我们之前谈到的“预期性品味”，即你在事件真正发生之前，就在某种程度上进行期待、积累期待并享受它。确实如此，想象它，它的快乐，提醒自己我有多么渴望这件事发生，而它终于要发生了。我的意思是，我所有的亲人和最亲近的人都在那里，这是一个重返我生命中重要部分的机会。弗雷德带着品味每一刻的意图迎来了梦想之日。当我早上起床时，像往常一样，这是仪式中令人兴奋、激动的一部分，在黑暗中醒来，在小屋里喝咖啡，拿着地图，整理装备，
to me there, and a chance to return to something that was a big part of my life. Fred arrived at the dream day with an intent to save our every moment. When I'm getting up in the morning, as always, part of the ritual that's exciting, thrilling, waking up in the dark, getting coffee at the cabin, taking the maps, getting all our gear together,
我们前一天晚上就打包好了，然后大概开车45分钟穿过黑暗，在偏远地区的碎石路上行驶，最终到达破旧的双车道公路。然后到达滑雪缆车底部的步道起点，前方有1500英尺的徒步路程，草地上全是露水。当太阳升起时，景象壮丽无比。对我来说，这看起来就像我一遍又一遍做的那个梦，
we packed the night before, and then probably about 45 minutes driving through the dark, on dirt gravel roads through this remote area, finally reaching beat up to lane highway. And then on to the trailhead at the bottom of the ski lift with the 1500 foot hike ahead of us, there was dew all over the grass. And it was glorious as the sun was rising. To me, it seemed like the dream I'd had over and over
我能够做到这一点。我一直告诉我的朋友们，有他们在身边是多么令人高兴。这曾经是我无法想象的事情，但却是我非常渴望的事情。清新的空气，壮观的景色，随着太阳升起，每一分钟都变得越来越好。
that I'd be able to do this. And I kept telling my friends what the delight it was to have them there. That this was once something I could never imagine but something I wanted so much. And the crisp air, the spectacular view, the better and better every minute as the sun got higher.
我记得当时想，这真是莫大的福分。在我们上方的薄雾中，可以看到山顶。然后沿途停下来拍照，记录下每一步，提醒自己我有多么渴望能够做到这一点。然后到达山顶，欢呼雀跃，拥抱，跳跃庆祝，告诉朋友们我有多爱他们，泪水顺着我的脸颊流下。舞台已经搭好，地面已经铺好，准备迎接那天晚上的盛大庆祝活动。我听到的一件事，当然，这不仅仅是因为你去登山而感到快乐，但在某种程度上，这一定感觉像是你获得了一次缓刑。
I remember thinking, this is what a blessing this is. Above us in the mist, it was this mountain top that we could see. And then along the way, stopping for photos, documenting each step along the way, reminding myself of how much I wanted to be able to do this. And then getting to the summit, hooping and hollering, hugging, jumping for joy, telling my friends how much I love them, tears streaming down my eyes. The stage was set and the ground was tiled and ready for this mega celebration that evening. One of the things I'm hearing, of course, is this is not just a happy day because you went mountain climbing, but in some ways it must have felt like you had been granted a reprieve.
哦，就像我在断头台前刚刚获得赦免一样。我简直不敢相信这一切正在发生。我一直说这看起来不真实。感觉就像我获得了第二次机会。你心想，以后我会一直小心我的背。我再也不会把任何事情视为理所当然了。我得到了重来的机会。这比我能想象的还要精致。告诉我当你开始下山时发生了什么？上山是一回事。
Oh, it's as if I've been granted clemency on the scaffold right before. The guillotine came down. I just could not believe that this was happening. I kept saying this doesn't seem real. It seems like I've been given a second chance. You think, and then I'll always be careful with my back. I'll never take anything for granted again. I get a do over. This is just more exquisite than I could have imagined. And tell me what happened as you started coming down? Going up was one thing.
下山完全是另一回事。当你走下相当于一座高层建筑的1500英尺左右的路程时，会有相当大的冲击力。在步道松散的路段，会有一些滑倒和稳住身体的情况，有些地方非常陡峭。每一次这样的情况，背部都会受到一种冲击，腰部下段会有一些减震。起初我没多想。然后当我们走得更远时，它开始悄悄向我袭来。我开始感到背部紧绷，我开始把所有的注意力都集中在背部这种不适感上。
Coming down was entirely another. There's quite a bit of pounding as you're coming down the equivalent of a tall skyscraper 1,500 feet or so. And there was some slipping and catching yourself on loose sections of the trail, very steep in spots. And each one of these times there'd be a kind of a pound on the back and some shock absorbing going on in the lower lumbar. At first I didn't think much of it. Then it started to creep up on me as we came farther down. I started to feel tightness in the back and I began to focus all my attention inward on this unpleasant
还没等我反应过来，我就开始感到腿部后侧有一点刺痛。哦，不。这和我手术前的感觉一模一样。我开始试着不去想它。“没事的。别去想它。”
tension in the back. And before I knew it, I was starting to feel a little tingling in the backs of the legs. Oh, no. And this was a downical to the sensations I'd had before the surgery. And I began to just forget about it. It'll be fine. Don't even think about it.
但随着我继续走，我开始感觉到更多。我的脚趾感到一阵刺痛。坐骨神经痛顺着腿后部一直延伸到脚后跟，我开始害怕了，我开始出汗。所以很快，它从最美丽的缓刑、第二次机会，变成了现在，我想，我搞砸了，我想我再次弄伤了椎间盘。现在我想我搞砸了，我想我再次弄伤了椎间盘。
But as I moved on, I began to feel more and more of it. I felt a little twinge in my toes. A bit of sciatic at down the back of the leg into the heel, I'm starting to get scared, and I'm starting to sweat. So very quickly, it was going from the most beautiful reprieve, the second chance to now, I think, I've blown it, and I think I re-entered the disc. Now I think I've blown it, I think I re-entered the disk.
我的意思是，这里的感觉是，你拥有了这么好的东西，你得到了这次奇迹般的缓刑，你的背部恢复了，而你基本上变得贪婪，然后搞砸了。完全正确。我一遍又一遍地责怪自己，我真不该这么做。我当时在想什么？我无法再经历一次背部手术了。我必须学会忍受疼痛。非常害怕。
I mean, the feeling here is that you had it so good, you got this miraculous reprieve, your back came back, and you basically got greedy and blew it. That's exactly right. I kicked myself over and over, should never have done this. What was I thinking? That I couldn't go through another back surgery. I have to learn to live with the pain. Very scared.
当我们回到车里时，我知道有些不对劲。我们上了车开车回去。但我让他们全程开车。我只是在想我的背。情况逐渐恶化。直到该做晚饭的时候，我感觉不对劲。所以我最终说，我感觉不对劲。
By the time we got back down to the car, I knew that something wasn't right. We got in the car and drove back. But I let them drive the whole way. I'm just thinking about my back. It got progressively worse. Till it's time to cook dinner, I don't feel right. So I ended up saying, I don't feel right.
所以我最终说，我做不到。我必须去敷冰块，躺在后卧室里。庆祝活动蒸发了。虽然有晚餐什么的，但我无法参与其中。我简直不知所措。我非常害怕。我只是无法和人待在一起。他们想庆祝，想玩得开心。我以为我永远无法参与其中。我想你一定在回到家后就预约了医生。我预约了。然后他让我做了一些身体测试和不同的动作，他说：“好吧，你没事。”
So I ended up saying, I can't do this. I have to get on the ice and lie down in the back bedroom. And the celebration evaporated. There was dinner and all, but I could not be a part of it. I just was beside myself. And I was terrified. I just couldn't be around people. And they wanted to celebrate and have a good time. I thought I could never be a part of it. I imagine you must have made an appointment to see your doctor as soon as you got back home. I did. Then he put me through some physical tests and different motions and he said, okay, you're fine.
我说：“什么？我没事？你只是拉伤了。它会消失的。”我说：“你怎么知道？我以前见过这种情况。你应该给我打电话。我会告诉你通过电话做几件事。我诊断过了。”我们许多人都有过像弗雷德那样的经历。一切都准备就绪，让我们去品味一个美妙、难忘的时刻。然后焦虑或其他不受欢迎的情绪阻碍了我们的享受。
I said, what? You're fine. You just strained it. It'll go away. I said, how do you know that? I've seen this before. You should have called me. I would have told you to do a few things and they're over the phone. I did diagnose it. Many of us have had an experience like Fred's. Everything is in place for us to save a wonderful, memorable moment. And then anxiety or some other unwelcome emotion gets in the way of our enjoyment.
当我们回来时，我们将探讨有助于我们保持关注生活中美好事物的实用品味策略。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天早上我在华盛顿特区的一个林区散步。当我不经意间瞥见一只秃鹰时。它优雅地绕过一个弯，停在溪流上方70英尺的一根树枝上。我不需要心理学家告诉我放慢脚步去欣赏美景。但生活并不总是把机会放在盘子里让我们去品味生活中的其他美好事物。有时，事实上经常，我们需要付出一点努力。弗雷德，你谈到了触发因素和策略之间的区别
When we come back, practical strategies for savoring that will help us stay focused on what is good in our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I was in a walk this morning in a wooded area of Washington DC. When out of the corner of my eye, I spotted a bald eagle. It gracefully rounded a corner and alighted on a branch, 70 feet above a stream. I didn't need a psychologist to tell me to slow down and enjoy the view. But life does not always hand us opportunities on a platter to save other good things in life. Sometimes, often in fact, we need to exercise a little effort. Fred, you talk about the difference between triggers and strategies
当谈到品味时。你能解释一下这些概念之间的区别吗？触发因素是发生在我们身上的事情，是我们对其做出反应的事情，比如陌生人的赞美。它是突如其来的，所以有惊喜的快乐，如果我们允许的话，这可以唤起品味。如果我们只是继续前进，例如，就像你看到那只秃鹰时，你本可以说：“好吧，我不能坐在这里看这个。我还有别的地方要去。我下次再看吧。”另一方面，策略是我们自愿采取的，我们实际上计划了一个品味机会。我们为它搭建舞台。
when it comes to savoring. Can you explain the difference between those ideas? A trigger is something that happens to us, something to which we react, say a complement from a stranger. It came out of the blue, so there's the joy of surprise, that can evoke savoring if we allow it. If we just move on, for example, with the bald eagle, as you saw it, you could have said, well, I can't sit here and look at this. I've got some place I need to be. I'll see this another time. On the other hand, the strategies are put in place on our own voluntarily, where we actually plan a savoring opportunity. We set the stage for it.
我们放下忧虑和烦恼。我们开始以一种允许它在我们的时间里发生的方式进行计划，在我们想要它发生的地方和时间。我们可以遇到这两种形式的机会，即意外的触发因素或精心策划的策略。有些人更倾向于等待。当机会出现时，他们可能表现得很好，被邀请参加某事或意外遇到某人，然后让它自然展开。
We set aside worries and cares. We begin to plan for it in a way that will allow it to happen on our time, and where we want it to and when we wanted to. We can encounter these opportunities of either form, the unexpected trigger or the well-planned strategies. Some people are more keen to wait. They might be very good when presented with an opportunity, invited to something or meet someone unexpectedly and let it unfold.
我有很多朋友非常自发，他们顺其自然。他们在这方面真的很擅长。和他们在一起很有趣，但他们没有投入大量的准备和时间来打基础。所以触发因素很棒，但你多久能看到一次呢？
I have numerous friends who are very spontaneous and they go with the flow. They're really good at that. They're fun to be with, but they don't put a lot of preparation and time into laying the groundwork. So the triggers are great, but how often are you going to see them?
你可能会错过它们，或者你向左走，而触发因素本应在你走路时的右边。你可能会提前结束散步而没有看到那只鹰。那是一种触发因素。而不是说：“好吧，我要去那个美丽的地方度过一个上午，我要看看我能看到什么，无论是什么。我要看看我能注意到多少东西。”那将是一种更具战略性的、主动的品味形式。
You may miss them, or you take a left and the trigger would have been on the right as you're walking. You may miss them, or you take a left and the trigger would have been on the right as you're walking. You might have ended your walk early and not seen the eagle. That's a kind of trigger. As opposed to saying, well, I'm going to go and spend the morning in that beautiful place, and I'm going to see what I see, whatever it is. And I'm going to see how many things I can notice. That would have been a more strategized form of saving that's proactive.
所以有一句名言通常归功于19世纪美国小说家纳撒尼尔·霍桑。“幸福是一只蝴蝶，当你追逐它时，它总是遥不可及，但如果你静静地坐下，它可能会落在你身上。”我听到你说的是，我们不需要被动地等待幸福的蝴蝶落在我们身上。我们可以主动做一些事情来培养那种幸福。完全正确。我会说霍桑不知道他在说什么。
So there's a quote that's commonly attributed to the 19th century American novelist Nathaniel Hawthorne. Happiness is a butterfly which went pursued is always beyond our grasp, but which, if you will sit down quietly, may alight upon you. What I'm hearing you say is that we need not passively wait for the butterfly of happiness to land on us. There are things we can actively do to cultivate that happiness. Exactly. I would say Hawthorne didn't know what he was talking about.
他可能有点太忧郁了，但这也许是他那个时代的产物。你不必被动地坐着等待它落在你身上。你可以去它们所在的地方。你可以在自己身上涂上蜂蜜，看看什么能吸引它们。你可以坐在它们会来的花丛中。你可以阅读关于它们的信息，以及一天中最容易遇到它们的时间。但关键在于，如果你知道自己在做什么，这是一种技能。这就像说你永远无法拉小提琴。如果你幸运的话，你可能会在琴弦上拉动琴弓，可能会发出声音。那是你所能得到的最好的结果。
He got a little bit too much melon-colleys maybe, but maybe that's a product of his times. You don't have to sit passively and wait for it to light on you. You can go to where they are. You can smear honey on yourself, what might attract them. You can sit amongst the flowers where they come. You can read about them, and the time of day when it most easily could counter them. But the idea is that if you know what you're doing, this is a skill. It's like saying you'll never be able to play the violin. If you're lucky, you might draw the bow across the string and you might make a sound. That's the best you get
得了吧，你可以上课，你可以练习。有些人经验丰富，在品味方面非常有天赋，他们以最好的方式直接进入体验，就像一位经验丰富的旅行者在风景优美的火车旅行中找到最好的座位一样。他们确切地知道去哪里，如何实现它。如何实现它。你谈到了你在西弗吉尼亚探险期间是如何错过品味一个潜在的非常愉快的体验的。在那次事件几年后，你确实成功地充分品味了一个对你有意义的个人成就。你爬上了科罗拉多落基山脉麋鹿山脉的斯诺马斯山顶，那是一座海拔超过14000英尺的山峰。
out for. Come on, you could get lessons, you could practice it. Some people are so experienced, so talented at ex-Avery, that they go straight to the experience in the best possible way, like a seasoned traveler goes to the best seat on a scenic train ride. They know exactly where to go, how to make it happen. how to make it happen. You talked about how you missed out on savoring a potentially very enjoyable experience during your West Virginia expedition. A few years after that incident, you did manage to fully savor a personal achievement that was meaningful to you. You climbed to the top of Snowmass Mountain in the elk range of the Colorado Rockies, a peak that rises more than 14,000 feet.
你回到大本营后不久就在日记中写下了这次经历。我想知道你是否可以为我们读一下那篇日记的一部分。哦，是的。我写道：“我对这一刻的短暂性有强烈的感知，我特别努力地去捕捉它。我想在余生中记住这一刻，所以我主动且刻意地构建了关于它的记忆。我缓慢地转了一个圈，让我的眼睛寻找它们觉得吸引人的东西。”
You wrote about the experience in your diary shortly after returning to base camp. I'm wondering if you might read part of that diary entry to us. Oh, yes. I wrote, I have a strong sense of the fleetingness of the moment, and I make special efforts to capture it. I want to remember this moment for the rest of my life, so I build the memory of it actively and deliberately. I slowly turn in a circle and let my eyes seek out what they find attractive.
“我注意到我下方压倒性广阔空间中的微小细节。一块皱巴巴的翡翠色和橄榄色拼布是白杨和云杉的森林。一条在阴影中蜿蜒穿过的银色细丝带是一条河流。一把随机散落在地上的银币是我们营地附近的一组湖泊。当我为周围的环境制作心理电影时，我注意到了所有这些以及更多东西。”所以我很好奇，弗雷德，你能拆解一下你当时在做什么吗？你称之为主动记忆构建。你能告诉我们你做了什么吗？我想能够记住那一刻的美妙之处。所以我开始寻找它，
I notice tiny details in the overwhelming expanse beneath me. A wrinkled quilt of emerald and olive patches is a forest of aspen and spruce. A thin silver ribbon zigzagging through the shadows is a river. A handful of silver coins strewn randomly on the floor, is a group of lakes near our camp. All these things and more I notice is I make a mental movie of what surrounds me. So I'm wondering, Fred, if you can unpack what you were doing here, you call this active memory building. Can you tell us what you did? I wanted to be able to remember what was so wonderful about the moment. So I began looking for it,
寻找它。我想，我想要记住什么？如果我闭上眼睛再睁开，外面有什么是如此美丽、如此强大，以至于真正是这一刻的精髓？开阔的广阔空间令人震撼。那是我渴望攀登多年的山峰。曾经有一次，我被拒绝了，我和我最喜欢的登山伙伴在一起。我们知道我们在上面只有几分钟。
hunting for it. I thought, what would I want to remember? If I just close my eyes and open them, what is it out there that is so beautiful, so powerful that really is the essence of this moment? The open expanse was overwhelming. It was a mountain I'd long to climb for years. And once before, been turned back on, I was with my favorite climbing companions. We knew we only had a few minutes up there.
山顶的岩石，我永远不会忘记，它是一座方尖碑。不像我爬过的任何其他山顶，我去过数百座高山。这座山顶岩石令人惊叹。意识到它可能被闪电击中过。数千次，可能在数百万年间，而我们在这里待了一会儿。风，开放感。我闭上眼睛，我能感觉到我们周围的广阔。我们在云层之上的一个开放空间。我记得当时想，我想记住岩石有一种气味。
The summit rock, I'll never forget, it's an obelisk. Unlike any other summit I've been on, I've been on hundreds of high peaks. This summit rock was astonishing. Realizing it had been struck by lightning. Thousands of times, probably, over the millions millions of years and we were here for a moment The wind the openness of I closed my eyes I Can feel the expanse all around us. We were in an open place above the clouds I remember thinking I want to remember that the rocks had an odor about them
所以我开始构建关于气味的记忆，就像是，我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。
So I began building a memory of the odor of was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset.
我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我不是有点难过。我只是说，我希望我能留住这一刻。最好的方法是尝试构建这段记忆。你还谈到了一个叫做“高度时间意识”的概念，即提醒自己你所经历的是短暂和易逝的。跟我说说那个策略。
I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I was like, I'm not a little upset. I just said, I wish I could hold on to this moment. The best way to do it is to try to build this memory. You also talk about this idea called heightened temporal awareness, which is to remind yourself that what you're experiencing is transient and fleeting. Tell me about that strategy.
那是你很久以前在询问人们在快乐时刻使用什么策略（如果有的话）来尝试充分利用它们时发现的。这就是意识到这一刻的短暂性的想法，在采访成年人、年轻人时。有些人报告说，这给了他们动力、能量、动机去抓住这一刻。没有哪一刻会重来。每一刻都被品味得比一块玉石更珍贵，因此这种对时间限制的意识，即它转瞬即逝的事实，使它变得更加美丽和特别，就像一朵花。
That's something you discovered long ago in asking people what strategies, if any, they used in happy moments to try to make the most of them. And this is the idea that you become aware of the fleetingness of the moment, in interviewing adults, young adults about this. Some people reported that it gave them the momentum, the energy, the motivation to seize the moment. No moment comes twice. Each moment is saved more precious than a span of jade, and so that the awareness of this time-boundedness, the fact that it's here and gone, makes it all the more beautiful and special, like a flower.
在沙漠中，也许它在雨后只会短暂地绽放。这是一种可以提高对这一刻欣赏的策略，意识到它很快就会消失。这是你抓住它的机会。所以一个相关的想法是，即使我们没有经历什么壮观的事情，我们没有站在山顶，没有观看秃鹰，也没有看到美丽的日落，我们的日常生活中也有一些我们可以欣赏的事情，特别是如果我们进行一种你称之为“向下享乐主义比较”的对比。
In the desert, maybe it blooms only briefly after a rainfall. It's, is a strategy that can heighten the appreciation of the moment, to realize that it's here shortly. This is your chance to grab it. So a related idea is that even when we're not experiencing something spectacular, we're not standing at the top of a mountain top or watching a bald eagle or seeing a beautiful sunset, there are things about our daily lives as well that we can appreciate, especially if we draw a contrast that you call a downward hedonic comparison.
我知道你有时会在考虑是否要锻炼时这样做。向我解释一下这种品味策略。这个策略是想象它没有像现在这样展开的方式。这有时被称为反事实思维。所以在我锻炼之前，例如，可能是一个炎热的日子，你可以想：“好吧，我想我不会锻炼了。我总是可以再做一次。”我说：“好吧，也许我不能总是再做一次。事实上，记得有一次我不能跑步，当我背部受伤时，我愿意付出一切来能够跑步。”
And I understand that you sometimes do this as you're contemplating whether you want to exercise. Explain to me what the savory strategy is for it. The strategy is to imagine a way in which it hadn't unfolded the way it did. Counterfactual thinking is what it's sometimes called. So to imagine before I'll exercise, for example, it might be a hot day and you can think, well, I don't think I'll exercise. I can always do it again. I said, well, maybe I can't always do it again. In fact, remember a time when I couldn't run, when I had the back injury, and I'd have given anything to be
我的意思是，字面上，我以某种方式付出了财富。现在机会来了，而我说我不打算做。得了吧，这是我的机会。那是回顾过去以创造一种对比，享乐或感觉对比。我还学会了一个技巧，就是进入未来，进入一个我将无法再跑步的时间。当我的身体太老而无法做到这一点时，也许我在疗养院，我在轮椅上，
able to run. I mean, literally, I've given a fortune in a way. Here it is, and I'm saying I'm not going to do it. Come on, this is my chance. That's looking back at the past to create a kind of contrast, hedonic or feeling contrast. I also have a trick I've learned to use of going into the future to a time when I will no longer be able to run. When my body is too old to do that, where I'm in a nursing home perhaps, I'm in a wheelchair,
而我愿意付出一切回到我现在所处的位置。所以我想象，我闭上眼睛说，这就是正在发生的事情。我在疗养院，我被允许回去一次。我要睁开眼睛，我要年轻，我要能够跑步，然后我睁开眼睛。我在这里。哦，这太不可思议了。当然，这是假设的。
and I would give anything to go back to being where I am right now. So I imagine, I close my eyes and say, that's what's happening. I'm in the nursing home and I'm allowed to go back once. I'm gonna open my eyes and I'm gonna be young and I'm gonna be able to run and I open my eyes. I'm here. Oh, this is incredible. And that's sure, this hypothetical.
有些人会说那样想是病态的。但对我来说，这是一个技巧，但它有助于提醒我，此时此地有很多东西可以提供，很容易失去对它的追踪，它确实让我保持在我的位置，不要把事情视为理所当然。你知道，这很有趣。我觉得在我们的生活中，我们经常做完全相反的事情。我认为我们许多人会进行“向上享乐主义比较”。你知道，与我们过去经历过的美好时光，或者与那些看起来比我们过得好的人相比，然后我们就会进行比较，你知道，与我们过去经历过的美好时光，或者与那些看起来比我们过得好的人相比。然后我们就会，显然在对比中，我们目前的处境
And some people would say it's morbid to think that way. But for me, it's a trick, but it helps to remind me that the here and now has so much to offer, so easy to lose track of it, and it really keeps me in my place, not to take things for granted. You know, it's interesting. I feel like so often in our lives, we do the exact opposite. Many of us, I think, make upward hedonic comparisons. You know, to better times we've had in the past, or to other people who seem better off than we are, and we sort of then, comparisons, you know, to better times we've had in the past or to other people who seem better off than we are. And we sort of then obviously in contrast, our present circumstances
看起来贫困或不快乐。在某种程度上，这是一个我们可以做出的有意识的选择。我们是选择与更好的时光相比？所以我们在现在感觉更糟？还是我们选择与更糟的时光，甚至是假设的最糟的时光相比，以便在现在感觉更好？完全正确。我们有选择。然而，问题往往是自动的。我们在某些情况下在脑海中播放这些脚本，当有成就可得，并且有比较可做时，我们经常被教导要与比我们更好的人相比，这样我们才能进步并增强我们的能力，变得更好。
look impoverished or unhappy. And in some ways, it's a conscious choice that we can make. Are we choosing to compare ourselves to better times? So we feel worse in the present? Or are we choosing to compare ourselves to worse times, even hypothetically worst times, in order to feel better in the present? Exactly. We have a choice. The issue, though, is often automatic. We play these scripts in our minds in certain situations, and when there's achievement to be had, and there's a comparison to be made, we're often taught to compare ourselves to someone better than we, so that we can improve and enhance our abilities and get better.
你通过与比你更好的高尔夫球手一起打球，并比较他们的表现和你正在做的事情，向他们学习，从而在高尔夫比赛中变得更好。我认为向上比较有其地位，如你所知，但这种向下比较，它确实有助于放大我们所处时刻的积极性。品味不是一个结果。品味是一个过程。所以你必须让自己沉浸在这个过程中。
You get better at the game of golf by playing with golfers, who are better than you are, and comparing how they do with what you're doing, learning from them. I think that has its place, the upward comparison, as you know, but this downward comparison, it really helps to magnify the positivity of the moment we're in. Saving isn't an outcome. Saving is a process. And so you have to lose yourself in the process.
你不能太专注于你做得有多好，或者是否有人做得更好，或者你本可以做得更好。你失去了对实际情况的关注，你就错过了机会。你和其他人建议的一个非常有趣的想法是，通过不时放弃一些东西，
You can't be so focused on how well you're doing, or whether someone's doing better, or you might have done better. You lose sight of what actually is, and you've missed the chance. One of the really interesting ideas you and others have suggested is that by giving up some things from time to time,
我们可以磨练我们对它们的胃口和欣赏。所以基督徒在四旬斋期间这样做，或者穆斯林在斋月期间禁食，它们都是让我们更敏锐地意识到我们生活中拥有的东西，而不是把它们视为理所当然的方式。你能谈谈这个想法吗，即在某种程度上不时自愿放弃一些东西可以磨练我们品味它们的能力？是的，研究表明，在消费之前戒掉一些令人愉快的东西
we can sharpen our appetite and appreciation for them. So Christians do this during Lent, or Muslims fast during the month of Ramadan and they're both sort of ways of making ourselves more keenly aware of the things that we have in our lives and not taking them for granted. Can you talk about this idea that in some ways voluntarily giving up things from time to time can sharpen our ability to save with them? Yes, abstaining from something pleasant before consuming it has been shown in research studies
会增加我们在消费时对体验的享受。所以禁欲的想法是有道理的。这是很久以前发现的。有研究表明，人们吃巧克力。三分之一的人被告知只需继续做他们的事。在实验室吃巧克力，等一两周，回来，然后他们有机会再次吃巧克力。第二组是
to increase our enjoyment of the experience when we do a consumer. So the abstinence idea has got something to it. It's something that was discovered long ago. There's research showing that people eating chocolate. Third of them are told you just to go about their business. Eat the chocolate in the lab, wait a week or two, and come back, and then they're given a chance to eat chocolate again. Second group is
被告知在实验室吃巧克力。一周过去了，我们给你无限量的巧克力，让你在一两周内想吃多少就吃多少。回来，然后他们在实验室吃巧克力。第三组有机会吃巧克力，然后被告知，一两周内不准吃巧克力。你必须戒掉它。回到实验室，和其他两组一起吃巧克力。
told eat the chocolate in the lab. A week goes by, and we're giving you an unlimited supply of chocolate to eat as much as you'd like for a week or two. Come back, and then they eat chocolate in the lab. The third group is given the chance to eat as much as you'd like for a week or two. Come back and then they eat chocolate in the lab. The third group is given the chance to eat the chocolate, and then they're told, no chocolate for a week or two. You must abstain from it. Come back to the lab, eat the chocolate with the other two groups.
他们发现，在一两周内没有吃巧克力的那组人，最终享受那最后一次吃巧克力的过程，比其他组要多得多。在某种程度上，你降低了你的基准。你净化了味蕾并创造了鲜明的对比，在没有吃一两周后，巧克力的味道比如果你一直
They find that the group that passed on the chocolate had none of it during the one to two weeks, man, ends up enjoying that final session, eating chocolate much more than the other groups. In a way, you're lowering your baseline. You've cleansed the palate and created the stark contrast, the taste of the chocolate having had none for a week or two is so much stronger and savourable than if you've been
吃个够很长一段时间要强烈得多，也更值得品味。这个想法可以在任何环境中应用。我经常在聚会或活动中进行短期的禁欲，我真的想享受它。我们都在一起。这太有趣了。我定期期待它。我会说，我马上回来，然后我离开。我会走出房子。我会去一个安静的地方，我只是坐着。这就像净化味蕾。我要回到那里。我要重新开始，回来并重新体验它的力量。所以我们可以在微小的方面做到这一点。在任何有一定时间的积极时刻，假期非常有助于这种策略。
doing it constantly to eating your fill for a long time. The idea can be used in any setting. I often engage in a short term abstinence kind of thing during a party or an event where I really want to enjoy it. We're all together. It's so much fun. I'd look forward to it periodically. I'll say, I'll be right back and I leave. I'll walk out of the house. I'll go to a quiet place, and I'll just sit. And it's like cleansing the palate. I'm going to go back in there. I'm going to start over, come back in and re-experience the power of it. So we can do that in miniature ways. In any positive moment that's got some time to it, vacations are very conducive to this strategy.
如果花时间独自一人，在一个安静的地方，然后再回到聚会的喧嚣、忙碌、兴奋和活力中。所以你还谈到了有时保持一些东西神秘是很重要的，试图非常彻底地理解它们实际上会剥夺我们品味的能力。同样，在这里，这似乎是意图。所以，品味涉及加强我们对某事的体验。为什么保持一些东西神秘有助于增强我们的
If times spent alone, in a quiet place, before going back to the hustle and the bustle and the excitement and the energy of the gathering. So you've also talked about the idea that it's important to sometimes keep some things a mystery that trying to understand them very completely can actually rob us of the capacity to save our. And again, here it seems like this is intention. So, savoring involves intensifying our experience of something. Why is keeping some things a mystery helpful in enhancing our
品味？好吧，一旦结果出来了，一旦我们解释了某事以及它是如何发生或进行的，接下来会发生什么，为什么某事发生了，这些事情给它画上了一个句号，我们就停止了以开放的方式处理它。研究发现，人们在阅读悬疑小说之前被告知结局，那里的魅力就消失了。只有当你不知道结局时，悬疑小说才有它的力量。所以拥有那种不确定性让我们保持专注和猜测。它也允许惊喜的快乐。但对于我们大多数人来说，我们喜欢一个直到最后都是谜的谜团。
savoring? Well, once it turns out, once we explain something and how it's happening or going on, what's going to happen next, why something happened, those things put a sense of closure to it, and we kind of stop processing in an open way. It's been found that people are shown the ending of a mystery before they read the mystery, there goes the allure of it. A mystery novel only has its power if you don't know the ending. So having that uncertainty keeps us focused and guessing. It also allows for the joy of surprise. But for most of us, we love a mystery that's a mystery to the very end.
我们不想读完结局然后回去重新开始读这本书。我们知道会发生什么。品味可以是极其个人的。它可以增强你的感官，并在你自己的思想范围内，调大那些给你带来快乐的事物的音量。但品味最有效的形式之一不是关于我们自己思想中发生的事情。它是关于当我们与他人分享快乐并一起庆祝时发生的事情。这就是我们回来时要谈的。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
We don't want to read the ending of it and then go back and start over and read the book. We know what's going to happen. Savoring can be intensely personal. It can heighten your senses and within the confines of your own mind, turn up the volume on things that bring you joy. But one of the most potent forms of savoring is not about what happens in our own minds. It's about what happens when we share joys with others and celebrate together. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家弗雷德·布莱恩特在芝加哥洛约拉大学工作。他与约瑟夫·维罗夫一起，是《品味：积极体验的新模型》一书的合著者。弗雷德，在你到达斯诺马斯山顶的那天，你和一群你已经一起攀登多年的亲密朋友在一起，当你到达山顶时，你们也花了一点时间一起庆祝，你们欢呼雀跃，大声喊叫，谈谈表达我们的品味对
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Fred Bryant works at Loyola University, Chicago. Along with Joseph Vieroff, he is the co-author of the book, Savaring, a new model of positive experience. On the day you reached the peak of Snowmass Mountain Fred, you were with a group of close friends with whom you'd been climbing for years, and when you reached the peak, you also took a moment to celebrate together, you were hooping and hollering and shouting, talk a moment about how expressing our savoring to
这里是《隐形大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家弗雷德·布莱恩特在芝加哥洛约拉大学任教。他与约瑟夫·维罗夫合著了《品味：积极体验的新模式》一书。弗雷德，在你登上斯诺马斯山顶的那天，你和一群相识多年的挚友在一起。当你到达顶峰时，你们还一起庆祝了一番，又喊又叫。请谈谈表达我们的品味体验如何
others can in fact heighten our own savoring. It's a really important observation. It's why it's more fun to enjoy something with others than it is to do it alone. I remember a photograph or a cartoon of a climber sitting on an edge of a peak looking off at this incredible horizon, at the sunset, and he's thinking to himself, this would really be beautiful if there was someone here to share it with. And the idea is that in sharing it with others, we magnify the joy. They tell us things that they're feeling.
事实上，与他人在一起可以增强我们自身的品味能力。这是一个非常重要的观察。这就是为什么与他人一起享受某事比独自一人享受更有趣的原因。我记得有一张照片或漫画，画的是一个登山者坐在山峰的边缘，望着令人难以置信的地平线和日落，他心想：如果有人在这里和我一起分享，那该多美啊。其核心思想是，通过与他人分享，我们放大了快乐。他们会告诉我们他们的感受。
They put into words their feelings, and we note that those are, in many in many ways our own or even if they're not our own We can appreciate those feelings in our own way. Other people or we might point out what it is about the moment that we cherish that we save. And in doing that we name it, we speak it and give it life and describing it and we have to understand our feelings. We have to be able to identify, label them and share them. So it helps us to actually understand better, identify what it is that is worth remembering in the moment.
他们用语言表达自己的感受，我们注意到这些感受在很多方面与我们自己的相同，即使不完全相同，我们也能以自己的方式欣赏这些感受。其他人，或者我们自己，可能会指出这个时刻中我们珍视、我们想要保存的东西。在这样做的时候，我们命名它、说出它，并赋予它生命，通过描述它，我们必须理解自己的感受。我们必须能够识别、标记并分享它们。因此，这实际上有助于我们更好地理解和识别当下值得铭记的事物。
My friends would often point out things that I would never have thought of. They might have said, come over here and touch this rock right here on the edge of the summit. So I'm touching it. It's pretty big boulder. He said, that's the one we were looking at last night. What? Yeah, from our camp. You see it down there? Oh, yeah, you're right. There it is. And I see it's just a flash of yellow and it's 3,000 feet below us. I never would have noticed that. And I would never have been able to remember it as a memory worth savoring if my buddy, who's since passed away, didn't share it with me. Of course, many people only do that about complaints. They're like a free reign. You know, tell me what you hate about this.
我的朋友经常会指出一些我从未想过的事情。他们可能会说，过来摸摸山顶边缘的这块石头。于是我摸了摸。那是一块相当大的巨石。他说，那就是我们昨晚看到的那块。什么？是的，从我们的营地看。你看到下面那块了吗？哦，是的，你说得对。就在那儿。我看到它只是闪烁着一点黄色，距离我们下方3000英尺。我本来绝不会注意到它。如果我的那位已经去世的朋友没有和我分享，我绝不会把它当作一个值得品味的记忆记住。当然，许多人只会在抱怨时这样做。他们就像拥有了某种特权。你知道，告诉我你讨厌这里什么。
Oh, yeah, this is horrible. This too. This too. You could say that savoring is kind of the opposite of complaining. It's flipping and inverting the negativity of complaining into the positive things. And that becomes habitual either way. I mean, it's also the case sometimes, you know, let's say you're sitting and watching a sunset with a few other people, you know, maybe everyone's watching the sunset. So it's not like as if each person is seeing something new and can draw your attention to something different than what you're seeing. But I would think that even in that circumstance, you know, talking aloud about what you're seeing allows the experience to go from becoming a solitary experience to a shared experience. It does. Some of the the most powerful
哦，是的，这太糟糕了。这个也是。这个也是。你可以说品味与抱怨恰恰相反。它是将抱怨的消极情绪翻转并转化为积极的事物。无论哪种方式，这都会成为一种习惯。我的意思是，有时候，比如说你正坐着和几个人一起看日落，你知道，也许每个人都在看日落。所以并不是说每个人都看到了新东西，可以引导你注意与你所见不同的东西。但我认为即使在这种情况下，大声谈论你所看到的东西，也能让这种体验从孤独的体验转变为共享的体验。确实如此。一些最强大的
moments in the mountains were shared and entirely shared after a nine-day backpacking trip deep in the Sierra. Coming down off Mount Whitney the last night spent sleeping out under the stars at 12,000 feet, watching these shooting stars over and over coming in. Realizing this moment we're on the edge of this this great escarpment the high Sierra the edge of it drops 10,000 feet back down to the valley below us and the morning we're to get up and hike back down, carrying all our stuff. But for now we are here. We were there in this stony expanse well above the timber lying there under the stars, watching and waiting and wishing, talking about the sky and how
在山里的时刻是共享的，而且是完全共享的。在内华达山脉深处进行了一次为期九天的背包旅行后，最后一天晚上从惠特尼山下来，在12000英尺的高空露宿星空下，一遍又一遍地看着流星划过。意识到此时此刻我们正处于这片巨大的悬崖边缘，高耸的内华达山脉边缘向下坠落10000英尺回到我们下方的山谷，早上我们要起床背着所有的东西徒步下山。但现在我们在这里。我们就在那片高出林木线的乱石滩上，躺在星空下，看着、等着、盼着，谈论着天空以及它是多么
angelic and timeless it is. And then my friend said, well, we've got to go to bed soon. But you know what, let's just wait for one more shooting start. This will be the last one we'll have at this trip. And we can all hope and pray that it'll be a wonderful event. Let's sit here and wait for it. We waited maybe 10 seconds. And the most vivid, powerful shooting star I've ever seen in my life, just streaked across the sky. It was the width of it. It was huge. Usually they're just a track. This thing was like a paintbrush going across the sky from east to west. And it just rushed. It took our breath away. We started laughing uncontrollably at this beautiful moment, the power of it. And we didn't want
天使般且永恒。然后我的朋友说，好吧，我们很快就得睡觉了。但你知道吗，让我们再等一颗流星吧。这将是我们这次旅行中看到的最后一颗。我们可以一起祈祷它会是一个美妙的时刻。让我们坐在这里等它。我们等了大约10秒钟。然后，我一生中见过的最生动、最强大的流星划过天空。它的宽度非常大。它太巨大了。通常它们只是一道轨迹。这东西就像一把画笔从东向西划过天空。它就这样冲了过去。让我们屏住了呼吸。我们开始在这个美丽的时刻、在这股力量面前无法控制地大笑。我们不想
to leave, but we realized this was the capstone. This was the accent point, the exclamation mark on the whole trip in a way. I'll never forget that we still talk about that. And we remind ourselves of that again and again and again, the magic of that night and of that moment lives forever. You know, in a similar vein, I think you've noted that each of us can provide models of savoring for other people. I want to play you a clip from the 1989 movie Dead Poets Society and the film Robin Williams plays an English teacher at a
离开，但我们意识到这是压轴戏。从某种意义上说，这是整个旅行的重点，是感叹号。我永远不会忘记那一刻，我们至今仍在谈论它。我们一次又一次地提醒自己那个夜晚和那一刻的魔力，它将永远存在。你知道，同样地，我认为你曾指出，我们每个人都可以为他人提供品味的榜样。我想给你播放一段1989年电影《死亡诗社》的片段，在片中罗宾·威廉姆斯饰演一名英语老师，在一家
boys boarding school. We don't read in right poetry because it's cute. We read in right poetry because we are members of the human race and the human race is filled with passion, beauty, with all man's love. These are what we stay alive for. Can you talk a moment, Fred, about how when we are able to save our things and we're able to model savoring for other people? It becomes easier for other people to notice the wonderful things around them too.
男子寄宿学校任教。我们读写诗歌不是因为它们可爱。我们读写诗歌是因为我们是人类的一员，而人类充满了激情、美丽和所有人的爱。这些才是我们活着的意义。弗雷德，你能谈谈当我们能够品味事物并为他人树立品味榜样时，会发生什么吗？这会让其他人更容易注意到他们周围的美好事物。
Yes, it almost gives them permission to do so. It gives people the space and time to allow those feelings out, to more fully experiencing them. The trust too, and the intimacy, and sharing the joys we find, you get back so much more than you could ever give when you share the savoring. You told me that your mother was instrumental in your life in helping you learn how to savor and modeling for you how savoring works. I understand that you've tried to teach your own daughters the same thing to stop and notice the wonderful things that happen to them. At the end of the day, there have been entire summers where you end each summer's day by saying, let's catalog all the wonderful things
是的，这几乎给了他们这样做的许可。它给了人们空间和时间来释放那些感受，从而更充分地体验它们。还有信任和亲密感，分享我们发现的快乐，当你分享品味时，你得到的远比你付出的多得多。你告诉我，你的母亲在你学习如何品味以及为你树立品味如何运作的榜样方面发挥了重要作用。我知道你也试图教你自己的女儿同样的事情，去停下来注意发生在她们身上的美好事物。在一天结束时，有整个夏天你都在每天结束时说，让我们把所有美好的事情都列出来
that happen. Walk me through what you've done to be a model for savoring for your own children. Yes, I started that when they were very young. And I began to look for opportunities. And the best opportunity was part of the bedtime routine. And you could talk with them about the adventures they had in the day and the adventures that they could have tomorrow, the things they could do and explore particularly in the summers.
带我了解一下你是如何为你自己的孩子树立品味的榜样的。是的，我在她们很小的时候就开始这样做了。我开始寻找机会。最好的机会是睡前例行公事的一部分。你可以和她们谈谈她们白天经历的冒险，以及她们明天可以进行的冒险，她们可以做和探索的事情，特别是在夏天。
So we would say, what can we do in Amara? Let's plan a big adventure. That's what we would call this savoring expedition. And my older one, which is, she light up, and it's going to be fun. What are we going to do in Amara? What can we do? So we would begin brainstorming. So we might plan a trip typically, say to the beach, or there's a rose garden nearby. So we could say tomorrow, we're going to do a big adventure to the rose garden. Really, what could we see there? Well, there's going to be rose buds. Yeah, there'll be rose buds. Maybe there'll be petals. Where would we find rose petals? Maybe on the ground. Yes, if they've opened up, they were once paddles. Do you think we'll find some?
所以我们会说，阿玛拉，我们可以做什么？让我们计划一次大冒险。这就是我们所说的品味探险。我的大女儿，她会兴奋起来，这会很有趣。阿玛拉，我们要去做什么？我们可以做什么？所以我们会开始头脑风暴。所以我们可能会计划一次旅行，通常是去海滩，或者附近有一个玫瑰园。所以我们可以说明天我们要去玫瑰园进行一次大冒险。真的吗？我们在那里能看到什么？嗯，会有玫瑰花蕾。是的，会有玫瑰花蕾。也许会有花瓣。我们在哪里能找到玫瑰花瓣？也许在地上。是的，如果它们开了，它们曾经是花瓣。你觉得我们能找到一些吗？
Maybe what we could do is collect some. So we would perhaps take a little baggy and we collect little treasures. Things that we would find that were interesting. They became momentos of this magical adventure. So we would look forward to it. We would plan it out. I have a reminder that we're going to go tomorrow. Just sharing the story brings back the sense of wonder in seeing the world through their eyes. That's one of the great delights of parenthood, particularly that first child, where it's also new, and you're beginning to see the world as you once did. We seem to lose that sense of wonder too easily. But then seeing it through her eyes, and we re-experience it, and then going to the garden and seeing there are petals
也许我们可以做的是收集一些。所以我们可能会拿一个小袋子，收集一些小宝藏。我们发现的有趣的东西。它们成为了这次神奇冒险的纪念品。所以我们会期待它。我们会计划好。我提醒她们我们明天要去。仅仅分享这个故事就带回了通过她们的眼睛看世界的惊奇感。这是为人父母的一大乐趣，特别是第一个孩子，一切都是那么新奇，你开始像曾经那样看待世界。我们似乎太容易失去那种惊奇感了。但通过她的眼睛看到它，我们重新体验了它，然后去花园看到有花瓣
and we're going to save them, and then look for the unexpected, the joys of surprise, find a snail. Wow, that's cool. It's pretty small. Wonder what its life is like. Does it have a life like we do? Does it have snail life like we do?
我们要保存它们，然后寻找意想不到的东西，惊喜的快乐，找到一只蜗牛。哇，那太酷了。它很小。想知道它的生活是什么样的。它有像我们一样的生活吗？它有像我们一样的蜗牛生活吗？
Does it have snail friends and snail family? Where could it live? Can we go looking for another snail? It's just, it's, you begin to see the world as they do and trying to show them these savourable things. We then eventually have to leave. All good things must come to an end, but we get to come back. So trying to turn the ending of something into a golden opportunity to repeat it. We come home and then we share what we found with my wife and then at night
它有蜗牛朋友和蜗牛家庭吗？它住在哪里？我们可以去找另一只蜗牛吗？这只是，你开始像她们一样看世界，并试图向她们展示这些值得品味的事物。我们最终不得不离开。天下没有不散的筵席，但我们可以回来。所以试图把某事的结束变成重复它的黄金机会。我们回到家，然后和我的妻子分享我们发现的东西，然后在晚上
going to bed. Remember last night we were here, it's come full circle. Now it's a memory, and we remember some of the wonderful parts of what are the feelings that we had, and it really bonded us very intimately and showing her that this is a very important part of life. It prioritizes it, not just relegated to a trigger that might happen every once in a while, but something that you can manage. Every bit as important as managing the negative side of life. So Fred, we've talked a lot about savoring the sweet moments of life, but there are also some sweet moments that are intertwined with sadness.
上床睡觉。记得昨晚我们在这里吗，这形成了一个完整的闭环。现在它成了一个记忆，我们记住了其中一些美好的部分，以及我们拥有的感受，这真的让我们非常亲密地联系在一起，并向她展示这是生活中非常重要的一部分。它优先考虑了这一点，不仅仅是将其降级为偶尔发生的触发因素，而是你可以管理的事情。这与管理生活的消极面一样重要。那么弗雷德，我们谈了很多关于品味生活中甜蜜时刻的事情，但也有一些甜蜜的时刻与悲伤交织在一起。
They're what we call bittersweet moments. I understand that you had a very powerful moment of savoring with your mother to what the end of her life. Can you tell me that story? Yes, I can. That's a very dear and precious memory. She contracted ovarian cancer And the chemo was hard. It worked for a while, then it compromised her.
它们就是我们所说的苦乐参半的时刻。我知道你在母亲生命尽头时有过一次非常强大的品味时刻。你能给我讲讲那个故事吗？是的，我可以。那是一个非常亲切和珍贵的记忆。她患了卵巢癌，化疗很痛苦。它起作用了一段时间，然后损害了她的
The blood vessels in her brain, she had a small, many stroke, and lost some functioning and memory. And she fought valiantly. As it got harder, it realized that there was only a limited amount of time that we would be able to spend time together. I lived far away and would have to drive back. And so I came in the summer. We had wonderful time together, but there was something missing that she had been unable to experience. And that was time and nature. She was very much an outdoor person.
大脑血管，她轻微中风，失去了一些功能和记忆。她勇敢地战斗。随着情况变得越来越糟，我意识到我们能在一起的时间有限。我住得很远，不得不开车回去。所以我夏天来了。我们在一起度过了美好的时光，但她一直无法体验到一些东西，那就是在大自然中的时光。她非常喜欢户外活动。
So I got this just a wham this this wild hair as a friend of mine from West Virginia said I got a wild hair this idea that we should just I'm going to get her in the car. We're going to go drive it down into this state forest. This is a place we had been before and cherished. So I floated the idea to her, and her eyes let up. I knew they would. She had never been able to get out and do these kinds of things, being bound to the treatments. And she was weak. So I said, I'm driving. You sit here, I'm going to pamper you, you're queen for the day. And she sat in the seat next to me and we took this drive and it was glorious. This was the heart of the summer, gorgeous weather, the trees were just verdant and everything was so fertile and beautiful, so rich and it's a very remote area and I put the windows down
所以我突然有了一个疯狂的想法，正如我的一位西弗吉尼亚州的朋友所说，我突然有了一个疯狂的想法，我们应该，我要带她上车。我们要开车去这个州立森林。这是我们以前去过并珍视的地方。所以我向她提出了这个想法，她的眼睛亮了起来。我知道它们会亮的。她一直无法出去做这些事情，因为被治疗束缚着。而且她很虚弱。所以我说，我来开车。你坐在这里，我要宠着你，你今天就是女王。她坐在我旁边的座位上，我们进行了这次驾驶，真是太棒了。这是盛夏，天气极好，树木郁郁葱葱，一切都那么肥沃美丽，那么丰富，这是一个非常偏远的地区，我把车窗摇下来
on the car, turned off the engine and we just sat and drank in the silence. It was a mountaintop moment in a valley. And it was a dark time and a dark period, but we were together in it. And I reached over and held her hand. And we began to look around in the blue sky. There was a cloud come across and iridescent in the sunlight. Little twinges of rainbow from the light
关掉引擎，我们只是坐着，沉浸在寂静中。这是一个山谷中的山顶时刻。那是一个黑暗的时期，一个黑暗的阶段，但我们在一起。我伸出手握住她的手。我们开始环顾四周的蓝天。云层飘过，在阳光下闪烁着彩虹色。光线穿过云层
trickling through the cloud. And there was a wind that came across this flower, studded meadow. And you could see the wind coming toward us, a wave of wind. And I came through the car. And I turned and looked at her. And she looked at me.
透出一点点彩虹的色彩。一阵风吹过这片开满鲜花的草地。你可以看到风向我们吹来，一阵风浪。它穿过车子。我转过头看着她。她看着我。
She saw the same wave of when coming. She laughed and we looked around. There was a brook, a stream next to us and it was gurgling. It was like a dream. Such a fairy tale place and an unlikely moment carved out of this really hard adversity. So we held hands and I would look over and she would just wink at me. carved out of this really hard adversity. So we held hands and I would look over and she would just wink at me. She had a tear in her eye, I had a tongue down my cheek.
她看到了同样的风浪吹来。她笑了，我们环顾四周。我们旁边有一条小溪，它在潺潺流淌。这就像一个梦。这样一个童话般的地方，在如此艰难的逆境中开辟出的一个不太可能的时刻。所以我们握着手，我会看过去，她就会对我眨眨眼。在如此艰难的逆境中开辟出的一个不太可能的时刻。所以我们握着手，我会看过去，她就会对我眨眨眼。她眼里含着泪水，我脸颊上流下一行泪。
I do now in remembering this, but those things, those tears in the pain, it was the price of the joy of that moment. And I would have paid at a hundred times over because we both knew in the backs of our minds that this might well be the last time we would be there. And it turned out that it was. But we just closed our eyes for a moment and let it come flowing into us. And I remembered I never want to forget this moment as long as I live.
我现在回忆起这些时依然流泪，但那些泪水，那些痛苦，是那一刻快乐的代价。我愿意付出一百倍的代价，因为我们内心深处都知道这很可能是我们最后一次去那里。事实证明确实如此。但我们只是闭上眼睛片刻，让它流入我们心中。我记得我这辈子都不想忘记这一刻。
Because only shortly after that, you know, she left this world. But we'd neither one of us would have given that up. The sadness was the price of admission. Fred Bryant is a psychologist at Loyola University Chicago. He is the co-author with Joseph Verroth of the book Savaring, a new model of positive experience. Fred, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
因为在那之后不久，你知道，她就离开了这个世界。但我们俩谁都不会放弃那一刻。悲伤是入场费。弗雷德·布莱恩特是芝加哥洛约拉大学的心理学家。他是与约瑟夫·维罗斯合著的《品味：积极体验的新模型》一书的合著者。弗雷德，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our aunts sang heroes this week, our Bob Boyle and Suraya Muhammad. Bob and Suraya both work at NPR,
Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是鲍勃·博伊尔和苏拉亚·穆罕默德。鲍勃和苏拉亚都在NPR工作，
and they graciously hosted the Hidden Brain team for a tiny desk concert earlier this summer. It was wonderful to spend time together, savoring live music, and we're so grateful to Bob and Soraya for making it happen. We hope you've enjoyed this year's U2.0 series. If you have, please take a moment to share these episodes with one or two people in your life. Word of math recommendations are the most important way that new listeners discover our work. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们今年夏天早些时候热情地接待了Hidden Brain团队进行了一场Tiny Desk音乐会。在一起度过时光，品味现场音乐真是太棒了，我们非常感谢鲍勃和苏拉亚促成了这一切。我们希望你喜欢今年的U2.0系列。如果你喜欢，请花点时间与你生活中的一两个人分享这些剧集。口碑推荐是新听众发现我们作品的最重要方式。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。很快再见。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。